hello everyone we are back at capo
Blancas first international tournament
it is of course the 1911 tournament in
san sebastian this is around 6 and
Capablanca has the black pieces against
the german chess master paul solid in
loan heart now he wasn't ever playing
for the world title or anything but he
has defeated many strong strong players
like turtle alert Irish names of a
charity with his fierce attacks and
often he won't brilliant surprises in
tournaments
due to his creative style and it will be
very interesting how his attacking style
well affairs against couple bunkers
positional style and also the game is
really really packs a lot of poison so I
do hope you'll enjoy it and we do have a
very nice photo from this tournament it
was sent to me by a subscriber this
photo is available online but not in not
in such high quality this is the the
best quality I've seen so far so thank
you for that as you can see these are
maybe not all the participants I count
17 people here so it's hard to say I
can't make out all of them but for those
of you who have really vast knowledge
you are more than welcome to name
everyone in this photo and also since we
didn't have a photo challenge for quite
some time now and this is a special
occasion
I am including a photo challenge in this
video who is the young gentleman in the
photo here there you have it we are also
going to return to this photo after the
game but for now best of luck to
everyone now getting back to the game 11
heart has two white pieces and he opens
with d4 and okay we have d5 see for the
Queen's Gambit is on the board east six
nights 2 C 3 and Capablanca goes once
again for the tower defense c5 we have
III Knights to a6 Knight to f3 and the
knight to c6 this is well is standard
theory today but was also standard
theory at the time the it was played
Bishop to d3 and now D captures on c4
something Capablanca always mentioned
that you should capture on d5 before
developing your lights were bishop
and when you don't a cup of Blanca will
happily capture as you already play the
move with your bishop now you're gonna
lose the temple Bishop captures on c4
and Bishop d7 making room for castling
we have castles by Lionheart castles by
capablanca and now if this was a played
in modern times we would most likely see
the captures Bishop captures Queen c2 of
the game continues but in those days
Queen to equal was a very popular gambit
you sacrifice a pawn and then you start
an attack against the black King and
capablanca had no problems with
accepting gambit so he grabs the pawn
seek after Sun before we have a capture
Sun d4 and now just Knight captures
Knight characters and Queen captures and
for this pawn white will get some
development in we have rook to d1 and
now Queen to g4 immediately capablanca
grabs a pawn and wants the trade Queens
Queen to G for white of course sir wants
to avoid any trades as for as long as
possible he would like to create an
attack against the black King and as he
does have the bishop pair he will try to
use the bishop pair to harass the black
Queen
so first f3 and now Queen back to h5 and
now comes Knight to e4 and here black
did grab a pawn and you you might think
black would want to trade down even
further but here you would really
centralize whites Queen and defend off
any any future attacks you would have to
most likely weaken the Kings position
so here Capablanca finds a different way
to trade Queens he plays Queen to e5 and
now it's not all that easy to avoid a
Queen trade here for example if you try
something like Bishop d3 what a black
will just ignore you Knight captures
with Bishop captures now at five and now
again you're forced to trade Queens here
Bishop here Queen captures Bishop
captures and so on
black will enjoy his extra pawn so here
Weiss it decides to trade Queens on his
own terms
we have Knight captures on f6 this comes
with check Bishop captures and now again
there's no way to avoid a queen trade
here you could try something with Bishop
e3 but then you're giving up another
pawn you don't really have
any compensation there so we have Queen
captures on e5 Bishop captures on e5 and
now a four so capablanca didn't run into
any opening tricks he defended well and
now he just gets to enjoy his extra pawn
but it's an extra pawn both players
still have both rooks the Bofors have
the bishop pair how do you push this
extra pawn to any advantage first b6
kappa blanka makes room to find care of
the light square bishop we have a five
attacking the the b6 pawn here and now
rush up the b7 we have a capture some b6
a capture some b6 rook captures an a8
rook captures and now comes b3 and here
we have a position where there's a pawn
on the Queen side for each player and
capablanca has an extra pawn on the King
side so how will he go about this well
this is an excellent position for you to
pause the video and just try and figure
out how to go about this position with
the black pieces I'll give you a couple
of seconds there I mean it's just I
figure out what white wants to do and
then play a move that prevents that and
allows you to continue you know pushing
for more advantage for those of you who
actually did it congratulations it's
quite a wonderful move and for those of
you who just want to enjoy the show
couple Blanca played Bishop to c6 here
it's indeed the best move you would
enjoy something like rook to e1 of
course but you have to be careful rook
to d8 would lead to the checkmate
but here with this bishop to see sets
move you are creating a wall here with
your bishops you're really limiting the
move the movement of whites rook on the
other hand you're preventing rook to d7
you do not want a district to land on
these seven and also you are preparing
b5 so your pawn on d6 is a weak point
once a white attacks it would rush up to
e3 you're either gonna have to go back
with the bishop which will be a passive
move or you're gonna have to play
something like Ruby eight which is
terrible this way you're preparing b5
and you're gonna defend it like that so
here we have Bishop to e3 by Lenhart and
now b5 pushing white the bishop back
Bishop to e2 and now comes f6 now black
is no longer in any dangerous of any
background
mates as king does have an escape route
Kingdom coming to play king of seven
King is seven and so on
be an active member of the endgame we
have looked the c1 attacking the bishop
but now Capablanca goes and Trey's even
further we have rook to e1 rook captures
Bishop captures and now comes came to
have two now both of them will try and
get their King as active as possible
King to f7 we have King the e1 and now
comes see five there is no danger in
opening up this diagonal as the c-4
square is a well guarded by capablanca
spawn so King to d2 we have King to e6
Bishop to d3 attacking the pawn here so
cover Blanca defends it and now h4
grabbing some more space on the King
side f5 grabbing some space in the
center here and here we have b4 it's not
the greatest of moves but there is
nothing better kappa blanka is the one
who is up upon what is fighting for a
draw and come on guys here to prove is
his extra point enough to push for
advantage here he plays efore a very
interesting decision we have f captures
on e4 and now while you could play F
captures and Bishop to e2 you would have
these two pawns blocking your own light
square bishop so Capablanca goes for it
differently Bishop captures Sonny for he
gives up the b5 pawn but instead of
grabs the e4 and g2 pawn so Bishop to e6
Capablanca now has a three to one
advantage on the King side but the white
also now has a passed pawn on the Queen
side and as you can see the bishop pair
also makes room for White's to be able
to push his own passport if you get this
Bishop let's say to a seven then all of
these squares are covered and white can
just start pushing his pawn so how does
Capablanca go about this first Bishop to
f6 attacks this bone forces black to
defend it we have Bishop to f2 and now
comes
Bishop to e5 controlling this square we
have b5 white starts pushing his past
pawn and now comes h6 preparing g5
we have b6 white pushes his passport
further
g5h captures H captures and now we have
bishop
my capablanca as we were sorry a bishop
to c8 with check King to f6 and now
first King to e 2 if you start with the
distant kappa blanka would go but of the
b8 and you would not be able to go back
up to a 7 and this this point will never
become a queen now
so after King to have six we have king
to e to white now has to stop somehow
stop capablanca King side pawns and also
somehow somehow get his light dark
square bishop to cover the b8 square
which is not all that possible like we
mentioned if you pull it upon couple
banco will just play Bishop to b8 and
well you can't put your King here and
play Bishop g3 to try and trade off this
Bishop which would be nice but it's not
possible
so our learned heart is just forced to
wait for any opportunity to present
itself
we have Bishop the c6 and now comes King
to f1 Bishop to d5 backup of Lanka King
tip King back to e2 and now Bishop to c4
with check King to d2 and now comes f4
we have Bishop to g4 Bishop to e6 now
offering a trade of bishops and now bush
or to f3 again controlling the b7 square
G for pushing the bishop back Bishop to
g4 and now even g3 Bishop to c5 and now
comes Bishop to g4 Capablanca wants to
start pushing his pawns even further and
as the bishop is covering the light
squares here you do have to prepare it
Bishop to g4 prepares f3
we have King te one and now f3 so two
very dangerous pass bones right here we
have Bishop to e3 and now comes Bishop
to d6 by Capablanca it's important to
mention that you can play something like
f to check here because my wife will
just snatch the pawn captures captures
and now you will not be able to win this
game but should be for check King g3
King g5 and after b7 white will just go
back and forth with his light square
Bishop and you will not be able to win
this game anymore so it would be too
great of an opportunity to squander
Bishop to d6 capablanca has to figure
out a different path to victory will be
seven now preparing Bishop to e7 and
queening the pawn so first King to e5
attacking the light square Bishop Bishop
the c6 and only now Bishop to b8 not
allowing this bishop to come to a7 we
have King to f1 and now Bishop to h5
capablanca makes room for his King to
enter the game via f5 g4 and h3 team to
g1 and now King to f5 bishop d5
preparing to check the white king once
he enters the King side King g4 and now
Bishop to e6
this comes with check we have king to h4
and now Bishop to d4 you can see that
even even while defending a terrible
position
I learned heart still manages to find
poison in the position for example if
Capablanca is not careful he could even
receive a nice checkmate like this
Bishop to h6 would be checkmate as the
light square Bishop covers the light
squares so of course couples Monica will
not fall for that but you do have to
give him opportunities to at least you
know maybe slip Bishop to g4 offers a
trade of light square bishop but also
makes room for his King to enter here we
have Bishop captures king captures and
now King back to f1 King to h3 by
Capablanca and the now comes the rush of
the g1 again offering an opportunity for
a couple Blanca to mess up if you go g2
with check here you will not be able to
win this game here simple King to f2 and
there's no way for you to win if we
check then King captures here and now
after you capture the best trip it's
actually white that means you get a
queen and after Bishop to h2 simply
Queen h8 will be checkmate
on the other hand after King to have to
if you try something like King g4 white
will just follow you King III King g3
now comes the bishop f2 check King has
to move and now you capture here and
again this check will come with Bishop
capture screen captures and again
there's no way to do in this game so
after Bishop to g1 kappa blanka doesn't
mess up he finds a different path to
victory
please brush up the c7 and now finally
white gets his birth up to a seven move
and here again if you play G to descend
this will not work we get into the same
idea King F - Bishop - H - now but now
simply King captures on f3 and the
bishop guards the g1 square you you
can't win this
so after Bishop to a7 we have King - H -
by capablanca and now we have b8 Queen
so again white has a queen in the game
will kappa blanka capture it so not all
that simple feel free to pause the video
here and try to figure out how to go
about this position I'll give you a
couple of seconds as it's a very nice
and game position for those of you who
decided that Bishop captures Queen is
the way to go unfortunately you will not
be winning this game because after
Bishop captures the G pawn is pinned you
cannot push g2 and once you move let's
say King here you'll just go back up d6
and there is no way to proceed the g2
check now King g1 and you cannot
approach with the King to support the
pawns so you'll just either have to move
the King and the white will keep on
moving the bishop back and forth or just
simply put the king - f2 and it's all
over
so here you will not be winning this
game so after this b8 Queen Capablanca
played g2 check and now it was in this
position that Paul saw in Lenhart
resigned the game as now the point is
already here and now whatever you do
let's say you go King to e1 now comes
the best rope capture screen and only
now after you capture with check you get
came to h1 and now there's no way for
you to stop all of the pawns for example
if King f2 you will simply go here with
Queen and the pressure up to a 7 then
you just a queen again for example you
get a queen Bishop captures King
captures do you control the f2 and f1
square the pawn is free to follow and is
the game over sir even you know
defending a terrible position throughout
pretty much the entire game has
I learned hard didn't really gain
anything for his pawn sacrifice he was
he was continually creating chance for a
couple Blanca to mess up well such as
even this one in in the far end game so
yeah congratulations to those of you who
found g2 you are an excellent player and
yeah that's it after G to learn how to
resign the game and round six goes again
to Casablanca so after six rounds that's
four victories and two draws for cover
Blanca not bad for his first
international tournament and also it's
very interesting this pawn sacrifice
Queen e2 on move nine like we mentioned
today we would most likely see captures
captures on c5 and Queen c2 continuing
the game just normally but in those days
you even though such moves were known I
mean it's not like no one thought of
this but it was a you know if you had
white pieces you you wanted more which
is something today in today's chess that
simply doesn't happen but yeah face
facing capablanca with such a pawn
sacrifice didn't didn't go very well but
yeah it's because of players like
Capablanca and players after him who
successfully defended against semi
correct pawn sacrifices that such moves
were out of big tournaments but yeah
like I mentioned we will be returning to
this photo congratulations to everyone
who was able to guess this is young
Vladimir Kramnik who today announced
that he is retiring from professional
chess so feel free to suggest a game any
game you want by Vladimir Kramnik put it
you know as usual hashtag suggestion I
will check it out as we will definitely
show a nice game by Vladimir Kramnik up
until that up until I decide which game
to show the first thing you will see in
the description below will be Kramnik
great victory of Levon Aronian
in 2018 candidate in the 2017 candidates
tournament it's really an amazing win in
the in the Berlin and none other than
you know his own opening that he used to
beat the Garry Kasparov so do check it
out it's really an outstanding game
will will definitely show at least
another one sir that's the game I do
hope you enjoyed it and that you're
enjoying the Capablanca saga so far as
usual you can check - on my previous
videos here I would like to thank Philip
Gobrecht
Yulia Colletti a Robert a maxi on Paul
staples and John tardy for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate that and yeah
have an excellent rest of your day
thank you all and I'll see you soon